نذهب مباشره عبر الهاتف من القاهره السفير
حسام زكيله من العام المساعد للدول جامعه
الدول العربيه سعاده السفير مرحبا بكم
معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء هل يمكن القول
بان الصفحه السابقه طويت مع دمشق هل نحن
امام صفحه هناك شروطا ينتظر تطبيقها
الواضح انه الدول العربيه اليوم اخذت
قرارا
بالعلاقه
مع سوريا مرحله جديده تختلف شكلا وربما
ايضا موضوع عن المرحله التي سبقت والتي
كانت مدتها حوالي 12 عام
وبطبيعه الحال كل مرحله لها
لها يعني
خصائصها ولها عناصرها ولها الاسس التي
تقوم عليها الوضع في 12 عام كان مرتبط
بالاوضاع الميدانيه في سوريا الان هناك
وضع جديد تطلب موقفا جديدا والدول الان
وصلت الى خلاصه مفادها ان
استعاده سوريا الى الجماعه وعدد سوريا الى
القطط الجامعه هو ربما افضل
للمصلحه السوريه والعربيه معا سعاده
السفير وبالتالي نعم مفهوم بانه خطوه
مقابل خطوه لكن هل من سقف زمني لتطبيق
الشروط وبالتالي ايضا من يضع اليه
المراقبه لتطبيق هذه الشروط
يعني شوفي حضرتك المسائل الخاصه باطار
زمني واليه مراقبه هي مسائل يعني ممكن
انها تنطبق على تواجد على الارض في نزاعات
من نوع اخر ولكن نحن هنا بصدد موضوع اساسا
الان اصبح موضوعا سياسيا وفي بعض الامور
التي تحدثت فيها دول يعني معنيه حتى اكثر
من غيرها لانها دول جوار مباشر مع سوريا
ولديها مصالح مشتركه
الكل يريد ان يحقق مصلحه في هذا الامر
والكل يعتقد انه المصلحه تبدا بمصلحه يعني
سوريا باعتبارها يعني دوله جزء من النظام
العربي واعاده الان الى الجامعه العربيه
الدول
والتي تاثرت تاثرا كبيرا
بالوضع الذي كان قائما على مدار العقد
الماضي فبالتالي
مساله الاطار الزمني هنا لم لم تكن مطروحه
وبالتالي هي ليست منعكسه في القرار الذي
وزعناه على الاعلام وموجود امام
المحاضراتكم سعاده السفير اليوم وقد عادت
سوريا لمقعدها الى جامعه الدول العربيه
يعني حكما بان رئيس السوري بشار الاسد
سيحضر القمم العربيه المقبله
نعم ستوجه له الدعوه لانه القرار يعتبر
انه العوده من تاريخ اليوم وبالتالي ستوجه
له الدعوه وتوجه
لسوريا الدعوه على مستويات اخرى الوزاريه
فبالتالي طبيعي انه اذا
راى
الرئيس السوري ان يحضر فهو سوف يحضر وهذا
امر طبعا يعني قرار لكل دوله ولكل رئيس
دوله
سعاده السفير لمين العام للجامعه العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط يقول بين قرار اعاده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه لا يعني اعاده الدول
العربيه لعلاقاتها مع سوريا وانه قرار
سيادي هل حضور الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
ان تم فعلا في القمه العربيه المقبله
سيكسر الجليد مع هذه الدول
بطبيعه الحال هناك يعني هناك تحققه
وزاد بشكل كبير من بعد
يعني ماساه الزلزال التي حدثت في مطلع شهر
فبراير ونتج عن ذلك عدد من اللقاءات
والزيارات مع عدد من الدول
ومن الممكن جدا ان نرى مزيدا من
التطبيع الثنائي لكن بس للتوضيح واجابه
الامين العام كان الهدف منها تبيان ان
هناك فصل ما بين المسارات الثنائيه الخاصه
بكل دوله مع سوريا والمسار المتعدد اليوم
المسار المتعدد يعني في اطار النظام
العربي الكل يعني توافق على فكره انه
العوده لسوريا لكي تشغل المقعد هو افضل من
غيابها عن المقعد في كل الفتره السابقه
سعاده السفير ملف اللاجئين احد المعضلات
الرئيسيه وكان دائما الحديث بانه يجب
الحوار اقله فيما يتعلق لحلحله ملف
الانساني وخصوصا اللاجئين هل حصلتم على
ضمانات وهل ستقدم سوريا ضمانات لعوده امنه
للاجئين وحتى في المناطق التي حصل فيها
تغيير ديموغرافي بحكم الحرب في سوريا
شوفي حضرتك هذا الملف يعني واضح انه ملف
يحظى باهتمام كبير جدا
بالذات من جانب الدول الاكثر استقبالا
للاجئين ونعني بها هنا لبنان والاردن
والعراق ايضا ولكن لبنان والاردن بشكل
كبير لانه تاثير مباشر على الاوضاع
المعيشيه وفي تاثر بكل الحاله الاقتصاديه
فطبيعي انه هذا الملف فهو ملف في غايه
الاهميه بالنسبه للكثيرين وايضا بالنسبه
التصور بالنسبه للسوريين نفسهم يعني الشعب
والمدنيين الذين
يرغب منهم من يرغب في ان يعود وكما تنفصل
الاتفاقيات الدوليه واتفاقيات اللاجئين
على العوده الطوعيه
للاجئين والكريم ايضا فطبعا هذا المسار
واضح انه ويكون مسار حديث
واحاديث مطوله
مع الجانب السوري وفهمنا من كل
الاخوه ممثله دول الذين شاركوا في اجتماع
عمان واجتماع جده من قبله انه هذا الملف
قضيه باهتمام كبير مع ملفات اخرى طبعا
ولكن
هذا الملف كان يعني يشكل اهميه خاصه
ونعتقد انه اللجنه التي تم تشكيلها سوف
تولي له الاهميه التي يستحقها نحن نشكركم
جزيل الشكر من القاهره السفير حسام زكي لم
ين العام لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات